from each of our perspectives we are the
center of our own universe and there's
this thing as if you give you just we're
totally just seeing yourself from this
cosmic perspective you would lose your
your identity
[Music]
welcome to the Rubin report I'm Dave
Rubin and before I do anything else make
sure that you're still subscribed to our
channel and be sure to click the solid
Bell so they actually get notified when
we post new videos alright now that
that's out of the way joining me on the
Rubin report today is a futurist the
geopolitical expert an author of several
books including hacking Darwin genetic
engineering and the future of humanity
Jamie Metzl welcome to the Rubin report
thrilled to be here Dave I am glad to
have you here sir because I watched you
on Joe Rogan and I was like I've got to
talk to this guy about all of this crazy
futuristic stuff it's crazy our world is
changing and it's gonna change whether
we like it or not and better for people
to understand what's happening and be
part of the process of change rather
than just sit back and let it happen to
us all right so I'm pretty sure we're
gonna have a dense hour of exactly that
but before we get into the new book and
and really the the meat of all of this
how does one become a futurist you know
it's it's a funny question er it's that
there's a funny answer so for my whole
life
I've really been thinking about well
what's what's coming next when I was in
law school there were a group of us who
were who were thinking about what is the
information technology revolution going
to mean and this is the very early days
of the Internet than the World Wide Web
and we were thinking we were writing
about it and so they have a lot of
articles from those early days that were
imagining the world that we exist in
then more than 20 years ago I started
thinking and writing a lot about the
genetics revolution I never called
myself a futures I was just a guy who
was thinking about the future and I was
going around I do a lot of speaking at
various events and they're all these
people who were calling themselves
futurists I thought well that's kind of
it how did they become futurists so like
I'm writing I write about the future I
talk about the future right I assume
they were varying like sort of silver
monochrome exactly yeah like in the Devo
hat and so one day you know maybe I'm a
futurist and so I was being introduced
if it was something when you're speaking
this hey will you give us a short blurb
about about yourself and I put Jamie
Messel is a leading futurist and then
somebody gave this little card like that
and said Jamie Metzl is a leading
futurist and I became a sight I declared
myself leading I hope I can I could live
assist it's like one of these things
where I come from a family of doctors
like there's a day when you become a
doctor you kind of walk there they give
you the thing you shake your hands you
take a picture these are kind of self
declared titles and so for me I hope
that every day I am being judged by the
things that I'm writing and the things
that I'm saying all right this guy says
he's a futurist
other people are saying that he's a
futurist even though they're reading
words that he's himself has written is
he saying things that make sense is he
inspiring us to think differently about
the future I guess we'll find out in
about 55 days exactly let's go back a
little bit further though yeah to sort
of where that sparked within you because
my audience knows I'm a huge sci-fi guy
there are so many of the things that I
think about and I think believed to some
extent that I've learned through stories
in science fiction as a sci-fi writer
and as someone that is aventuras or at
least on your business card what were
some of the stories that excited you
when you were kid
so it was just all of these stories I
mean these stories of exploring space
exploring humans I mean we are because
of the way our brains function we learn
through stories I mean that's been
probably the greatest mechanism for the
success of our species is our ability to
transfer information to each other and
we do it through this medium of stories
so just from when I was a little kid I
was a voracious reader I read you know
all the things that the right that
normal kids read I loved Narnia I really
I didn't realize it was the whole
Christian thing until it was much much
later but I just I just read everything
and I've always gravitated to the world
of stories and even in that I have a big
part of my life that's nonfiction even
in the national security world
then it's about it's about stories
because what is what is the Cold War
what is anything it's it's a story that
we tell ourselves and then we organize
around those stories yeah I'm always
fascinated when people watch see
something or listen to something that
like just blows their mind and and just
puts them on a different track and one
of the things for me 1997 I ate some pop
brownies and I was going to see Air
Force One with a bunch of friends but it
was sold out yeah so we ended up walking
to into a movie called contact which
none of us had ever heard of we had no
idea what we were walking into and I'm
sure you've seen the movie contact and
it was written of course by Carl Sagan
right and that opening scene the
panorama of the universe and maybe it
was the pop brownies and I was just
right time my life I was 21 but my mind
was blown and from there I read almost
all I think of Carl Sagan's books and I
just opened my mind to that sort of
thing and that's sort of what you need
in the world that's why you need it's
you know from a cosmic perspective we
are so small I mean there are so many
solar systems and so many stars and so
many galaxies just if you try to think
from the perspective of the whole and
then you think we're just this one
little tiny planet pale blue nothing
exactly revolving around one star one
Sun and but but from each of our
perspectives we are the center of our
own universe and there's this thing as
if you give you just we're totally exist
seeing yourself from this cosmic
perspective you would lose your your
identity but if we get so caught up in
our own little thing and we're not able
to see ourselves in this greater context
then also I think can be dangerous or at
least like it can make us less than we
otherwise could be and that's that's the
role of stories I mean stories help help
situate ourselves within ourselves
within our communities and within our
world and our world broadly defined
which part of what you do between
talking about geopolitics and dealing
with the future stuff and you know
writing sci-fi and all these things
which one is sort of excites you the
most or is it just it's all of a piece
you know so definitely my big passion in
life is to translate big scary sometimes
complex ideas into language that can be
shared and so when I write novels I mean
that's the whole point of my of my
novels is to have people enter into a
world and that's what novelists do but
in the world what I'd like is people
enter into a world and maybe think a
little bit differently about themselves
about what it means to be a human about
how we're interacting with our
technology now with with hacking Darwin
I'm doing the same thing is that that
there is this all of this incredible
complexity of the genetics revolution
there's like really hard science that
not everybody is able to dig into but
what I want to do is to take all of that
and present it to people in ways that
they can see themselves in the story and
once we see ourselves in a story then we
can be part of it we can feel empowered
to have conversations to have opinions
because I think that's this this crazy
thing of this moment is that radical
technology but it's AI or genetics or
nanotechnology quantum computing mean
they're going to change our lives in
deep and fundamental ways but people are
scared of the science and so there's
this in some ways it's like a
helplessness that these trends are
coming and they're bigger people feel
that they're bigger than they are and my
message is is not just that that's not
the case and that's a failure of the
scientists I mean this scientists need
to be translating the science so to
bring other other people along but
science isn't its own thing it doesn't
exist in some kind of imaginary
objective realm science exists within
the context of our societies and if we
don't recognize that dynamic interaction
which means that everybody has a role to
play then we're going to have really
warped outcomes that are going to be bad
for society and they're also going to be
bad for science all right so then let's
jump into some of those big scary ideas
and let's just sort of do 101 couple
things because I think that's really
what you're trying to do here in a lot
of ways is just take a wider group of
people and get them to understand
something so it isn't so so big and
scary so let's just talk about the world
of genetics yeah
general right now yeah so when someone
says genetics for the person that has no
idea what we're talking about
great what are you talking about and
that person is my ideal audience and I
love his people and they're sort of
afraid to admit it clear things frankly
that was what I loved my my interview
with Joe Rogan that's I know I think
that's why Joe Rogan is so successful in
addition to being a great guy because he
just he's this very confident as a
person but he's just asking common-sense
questions that the average person
probably would want to ask but when
they're when the average person
quote-unquote average person whoever
that is is faced with someone who's a
quote-unquote expert even a
self-declared futurist like me they're
kind of afraid of asking just some basic
questions they well what if what if it's
a bad question
maybe we all have that kind of event
agree so genetics so everybody everybody
I think understands that genes that
genes are part of the blueprint for life
and so to put it on a human level your
mother has an egg your father has a
sperm when that sperm fertilizes the egg
you have a fertilized egg it's a early
stage embryo it's one cell an egg and a
sperm that come together and in that
cell there is a blueprint for what
everything that you will become and so
that blueprint is written in a code and
that code is your genome and your genome
is made up of genes so it's a blueprint
for life love it let me pause it there
for a second so would you say at that
moment then once that coding is there is
that the beginning of what you would say
is life I mean this is this is of course
where yes assists and geneticists and
scientists and religious people have to
debate all these yes yes this is a
there's a political question which makes
it very difficult for us to it's very
difficult to think about that question
and just say well there's a scientific
question and there's a political
question because the whole thing is life
like is an egg cell alive yes our
ourselves alive yes is sperm Allah
yes but it's not on their own they're
not able to replicate which is one of
the hallmarks of life and so you could
say that that is the kernel of life
because life exists on a continuum it's
one microscopic cell but that cell if it
grows in the the quote-unquote normal
way it will it will become life so I
think that like I would never say that
the people who believe that life begins
at conception are wrong
imagining that it's because it's a
judgment call it's all on a continuum I
think that we can't say that but what I
would say is that there's a difference
between a single fertilized egg maybe
it's a single fertilized egg in a woman
or maybe it's in a lab like there's a
workout to that yeah and there's a
difference between that and like a baby
who's actually born and a 20 year old
person I mean they're there all the
politics at that but they certainly
there's no doubt that a single
fertilized egg is the beginning of of
life okay so we now live in a time when
we can start manipulating these genes
right talk to me about that disease you
know that's the crazy moment that we are
in now so we have evolved for about 3.8
billion years so life most scientists
believe began from these thermal vents
and the bottom of the ocean this first
spark of life and so all of life on
Earth is related it comes from that same
spark of life and all of life of
ourselves plants everything else had
uses the same building blocks because we
have that same that same origin and for
almost four billion years we've evolved
by the Darwinian principles of random
mutation random mutation means just
we're all different and and that's
really important because if from whether
we're seeing when we were single-cell
organisms or anything if everybody is
the same it may be good now but if the
environment changes and you're still the
same then you're going to die and so the
kind of diversity is really is really
important so it's random mutation and
natural selection natural selection just
means we are in these competitive
environments and some formulations do
better than others I mean they're like a
million podcasts does a lot better
yeah than others and it's that is a form
of natural selection that there's a
marketplace and and the certain set of
attributes and if the world changes like
you may be that you know we have no more
electricity and it's like or maybe we
get really there's no voice and the
people doing pantomime those are the
best podcasters hear anything so that's
basically just the that is the nature of
reality as being change we modify a long
road yes or uh so the core principle is
3.8 billion years driven by random
mutation and natural selection and now
we are recognizing for the first time
one that all of biology based on
genetics is a form of information
technology and like our traditional IT
it is increasingly readable and that's
what genome sequencing is and writable
and hackable and hackable meaning that
we now have these tools to edit the
genome kind of like a word processing we
can eliminate genes we can add genes and
so we are able to hack life and so we
are beginning after four billion years
this phase of our lives and our
evolution where we this one little group
of essentially monkeys that climb down
from the trees in Africa that we are a
we have the tools to recreate all of
life on Earth and it's this awesome
power and to quote spider-man it comes
with a tremendous responsibility
technically that was uncle then okay so
so so we have this idea now that we can
edit the genome right we can read it we
can edit it and all of those things so
before I get to the sci-fi part of my
brain which is right where all the scary
stuff comes yeah yeah what are some of
the good things that we can be doing I'm
so glad you asked that because I yeah I
speak about this stuff all the time and
I could speak for an hour 58 minutes it
like here all these miraculous things
it's so exciting but and then fill a
stream it's like they're just some
potential downsides we need to be
mindful of right and it's like at the
end people say like oh my god I'm so
depressed we're all gonna die so we
should be incredibly excited about this
revolution because it's going to help us
a ton so the first the most the
immediate impact is going to be how it
changes our experience of healthcare
right now we live in a world of
generalized healthcare based on
population averages so you go to a
doctor and you get treated based on
being a human if you have a headache
maybe you get a Tylenol but you find out
if you're one of the people who dies
from time'll by taking a Tylenol because
it's everything is based on on the odds
of most people will respond to a certain
treatment it's the same true the same is
true for about 88% of cancer treatments
we're now moving to a world of precision
medicine and so precision medicine means
that you're treated not just based on
your being a human but based on your
being you so any intervention is going
to be based on your individual biology
so they literally are going to be able
to look at your your genome is that the
right word well there's the genome so
there'll be a set of information so
it'll be your personal history your
family history your biometric
information other measurements and your
your genetic information but your
genetic information will be the most
significant foundation of your
electronic health record and that
information will be provided mostly at
birth
them so we're all going to be sequenced
at just just like what you get a Hugh
and a kid is born they do a blood test
with a heel prick mmm everybody in the
not just in future will have their whole
genome sequence and that will just be
part of their electronic health record
and so the exciting thing is one
everyone's going to get these this
personalized medicine and it will be
better medicine because it'll be
tailored for all of our biology but even
more significant we're going to have
billions of people whose genetic and
life information are in these massive
data sets and
we're going to be able to use big data
analytics to increasingly unlock the
secrets of genetic and information and
systems biology meaning that we have
systems of systems inside of our of our
biology and what that is going to mean
is we're going to have a lot of
information not just about why you may
be sick now but about how your life is
likely to play out from the moment of
birth you're going to know that I have a
greater than average risk of this
genetic disease for example and that's
going to be very actionable because if
you're a woman and you know that you
have let's say a 70% greater than
average chance of getting breast cancer
you're going to want to start your
screenings much earlier than somebody
who doesn't have that predisposition but
we're also going to have a lot of
information that it's not deterministic
but is probabilistically predictable
about certain things that have nothing
to do with health like IQ the genetic
component of IQ personality style may be
that we have a great potential to be a
fantastic sprinter or mathematician and
we're going to have to think very very
differently about parenting and about
life and a lot of this stuff can be
scary but it's very what it's also
exciting like imagine you right now we
have these terrible refugee camps all
over the world but we have Einsteins in
every one of those camps and we just
don't know who they are we do in Los
Angeles where we are now I mean there
are these inner cities and the crime of
inner cities I mean there's all kinds of
problems but it's just like we're
throwing human potential down the toilet
so people are worried about be about
genetic profiling and they should be
worried but what about all these people
who were throwing away if we knew that
that some kid who's like growing up in
terrible conditions like has this
incredible potential and who knows
whether any potential will be realized
to be like a genius musician or
mathematician even we would at least
think twice about not providing
resources to help people realize their
potential it's so interesting because as
you're saying all this and I can think
of all of the row
that we undo good things they have just
laid out there and then there's this
other part of me and maybe that just is
the the sci-fi dystopian part where you
think of all the ways that there could
be evil manipulations and population
control and eugenics and all all of
these things that seem wrong or just in
the wrong hands could could go up you
know just completely haywire but so do
you view that sort of choice yes I do
you view that as different than with any
other technology now or is this sort of
unique it's it's not different in that
every technology has their utopian and
dystopian potential uses what's unique
here is that this technology is so
powerful and it's coming at us so
quickly that we don't have the same time
that we've had to figure it out like
with steam I mean steam and electricity
and and even the using gasoline I mean
all these things they were revolutionary
but we had a little bit of time to
transition and this is the problems that
the science is moving so quickly that
the transitions like can't happen in the
kind of methodical ways and as
disruptive as they've been in the past
but there that will that will be much
more methodical than what's coming and
that's why we're there's a race and and
so every one of these technologies every
good outcome has a parallel story that's
a bad outcome and so for me I tend to be
all-in-all net-net
optimistic but the the technology itself
is agnostic and what's at play now is
the question of what are the values that
we are going to use to guide this
technology and I think that's that's the
game and that's what I'm trying to bring
people into the conversation to say that
if you are worried about a potential
dystopian outcome how can we fight
together to make sure that that doesn't
happen how can we bring people into the
conversation to say our well here's what
I want to see I want to have these
technologies used in ways that are
making our communities stronger that are
enhancing human potential in positive
ways but to do it we all need to have a
voice and to have a voice we need to be
educated are there people that just
focus on the speed
portion of this because for some reason
that really fascinates me like this
whole thing does but something this idea
that people all over the globe now
because of the internet and all the
other ways we're connected can all be
working on these things all at the same
time all be you know sort of jumping in
front of each other and faster and
faster ways and for all we know there's
all sorts of technologies happening in
China now that we have no idea about and
I want to relate this also yeah of
course to the geopolitical part which is
some countries are gonna have more
restrictions right on these technologies
and some won't and all of these things
so the speed part to me is just really
fast it's an essential piece of this
story just think about this that you
know hundred years ago 500 years ago
there were the same distribution of
geniuses that we have now but if you're
a genius 500 years ago somewhere in
Africa or somewhere in Asia you're kind
of on your own right you know Ramanujam
this kind of genius mathematician in
India he had like one book
I mean he's either from that one book he
kind of figured out this this incredible
system of math but now if you're a
genius most anywhere in the world like
you have access to the global library
you don't have to be in the Bronze Age
the Copper Age we had all these people
all around the world who are having the
same discoveries basically over in the
same pattern without being connected to
each other at all it's kind of a waste
of energy once a big copper got it
it's not right I'm just sending out the
email right right so Thomas said is it
figure something out and some guy
halfway across the world doesn't realize
though you know months ago that what a
waste of energy said oh no you don't
know buddy we're all interconnected so
everybody you don't you don't start at
the bottom of the mountain you start
kind of 2/3 of the way up the mountain
and you don't have to take a step that
has been taken by somebody else you
don't have to solve a problem that has
been taken that has been solved by
somebody else and so with Peter and
everybody in the world increasingly
being brought into this process we are
unleashing this imaginative
creative tidal wave that I just think
that people don't appreciate the
significance of that and that's why you
in this field of biotech and and
genetics pretty much every day there's
another paper that comes out that nobody
notices but if this same paper had come
out ten years ago everyone is world
changers everyone would have gotten the
Nobel Prize right there's like there's a
Nobel Prize ever like every sink no
garage worthy discovery in the context
of ten years ago every single day right
so okay so I think most people
understand the part that if we can if we
can map your genetics that then we can
watch out and know that you shouldn't
take this medicine or you should stay
away from this food or that sort of
thing so it's sort of a blueprint for
sort of how you can live and how you can
flourish yeah most maximally yeah and
yeah to identify so right now when you
have a dizzy you have a symptom and you
go to the doctor and then the doctor
tries to treat that symptom but maybe
this is a symptom something that's been
germinating in you for a decade maybe
it's something that results from a
genetic abnormality that you had since
the moment when you were that that
single cell that fled fertilized egg and
so it's going to change our model of
healthcare then from treatment of
symptoms to prevention so I think that's
and that's so doing all of those things
but in a way that's personalized for you
is I'm going to know I have a risk of
this certain outcome I don't want that
outcome to happen and so here are the
things that I'm going to do from the
beginning so that then gets us to the
editing portion of this right so okay so
now we know that you're predisposed to
XY and Z now we can start editing things
right to make sure that you are not
going to get surgery yes so what you're
talking about is editing that happens
after you're born and so there's a big
distinction between these two kinds of
editing there's germline editing which I
know we'll talk about which is editing
two sex cells and so that's primarily
embryos but also it works on sperm and
eggs and the reason why it's called
germline is it that's when you edit the
sex cells the sperm cells
the sperm eggs or embryo then that gets
passed on to future generations but if I
edit you or an adult not in the sex
cells then that's just for that person
over the course of their life and that's
why it's less controverts controversial
but it's less controversial so there's a
whole class of interventions called gene
therapies that are used to do exactly
that and right now for example cancer is
probably the best the best example so
there are a lot of people who have
cancer we all have these natural
antibodies that fight cancers but
sometimes people they're their
antibodies aren't working well enough
and sometimes they have a cancer that
just is is overpowering their antibody
so there's a treatment called Carty
therapy where you take out somebody's
blood cells and you genetically engineer
them to give to boost their natural
cancer fighting superpowers then you put
those cells back into the person's body
and that person becomes a genetic
superheroes this is sort of like
platelet-rich therapy right yes so apipa
is a much narrower much less systemic
intervention so yes but this is that
kind of quote-unquote yeah and so so we
are going to be in and so there's a
delivery so when the delivery is
happening through blood that makes it a
little bit a little bit easier but then
we have all kinds of what are called
specialized cells so you stop when you
in use doing your that single-cell
organism or single cell pre implanted
embryo you can't have the potential to
become everything but your cells
differentiate over time and that's why
you can have skin cells and liver cells
and heart cells and so when we're doing
these kinds of interventions for gene
therapies we're wanting to edit a
specific kind of cell what let's call it
a heart cell or something like that and
so there need to be delivery mechanisms
to do it and so when it's blood you can
easily take it out and put it back but
now there's all this whole other area of
research of using basically retrofitted
viruses because viruses for billions of
years have developed a machinery to kind
of infiltrate our bodies
and replicate so we take advantage of
that to deliver certain kinds of gene
edits to specific parts of the body to
treat specific types of problems and
that's not that's not fully ready for
primetime with humans there are some
very early clinical trials a huge amount
of work those is happening in this area
I don't know if this is exactly the I'd
point to mention this so where does
CRISPR fall into so CRISPR is the the
the among the best forms of gene editing
so if you have the genome and you're
making the changes at the genome there
needs to be a mechanism for doing that
and so there have been prior tools for
gene editing that were much slower and
more expensive than this tool of CRISPR
and it's called CRISPR caste 9 is the
most prominent but there are many so
basically there are these repeating
patterns in the genome and with the
CRISPR systems they can identify use a
guide RNA to find a specific place on
the genome and then with the caste 9
it's a cutting enzyme so you think
that's the double helix you go to a
place and then you have this little
knife molecular scissors and you cut out
what you don't want and then this the
the the genome will either reconnect
with that missing piece gone or you can
introduce an additional piece of DNA
designed to fit in that little space and
they'll be it'll be like oh we're
missing a piece of this bridge oh here
it is and that the cell will just
naturally put it there so I sense we're
getting into one of those places where
the average person is suddenly going
whoa whoa I'm losing it a little bit so
to unwind this a little bit though
because I think I think we've got the
right pieces yeah that doing all of that
then would allow people to be again
inoculated from certain diseases to be
able to maximize health and also for
generations then after to be able to you
know so why not have to deal with these
things let me make it very visual and
and concrete so I'm a member of the
World Health Organization has an
International Advisory Committee on
human genome editing which we were
created
at the end of last year 2018
after a Chinese scientist announced in
November that the world's first gene
edited babies had been secretly born in
China in October 2018 so these this
tools of using these CRISPR system to
change basically they edited these pre
implanted embryos of these two little
girls and what they did was went in and
they basically disrupted this one gene
which is called ccr5 no one needs to
remember ccr5 but just the genes just
all have different different names and
what the ccr5 gene when it's disrupted
people have disrupted copies of ccr5
mostly Northern Europeans have an
increased resistance to HIV because the
HIV virus can't penetrate into this into
the cell and so this was way way before
people thought and myself included
thought it was safe it felt like human
experimentation but these kids were were
born and so the world's first gene
edited babies are born and people go
straight from that and it's a huge deal
I think it was highly unethical of this
guy to do and then they they say are
well then the next step in people's mind
is it's like the you know then you know
the build-a-bear workshop we just like
right you just like I'll take one of
these one of these one of these and it's
not going to be that biology is too
complex for that but we are increasingly
going to have the capacity and it's
still it's the very very early days but
it's going to be more and more and more
to begin making a small number of gene
edits to potential future humans and
that's a really big deal so what was the
ethical conundrum there just because
this is still too untested yeah so so a
few things one it was just way premature
I mean it's a lot of people are doing
experiments on animals like mice but to
do these experiments on real live humans
I mean we know what I mean that that is
to me it's like we have the nerve
conventions about what is in is not okay
in this felt experimental do so and we
know for a fact that this has been done
it this has been verified in other
places or it could this possibly just be
a situation where I you know I if
there's a one percent chance okay that
this is a fraud in my view there's a 99%
chance that it is not a fraud and I know
a lot of people that I work with people
who know this know this guy ho-jon Quay
is his name so I think it's it I'm
entirely convinced that it's did Israel
but it was unethical because it was
premature because it was totally
untransparent because the work was
sloppy because the parents didn't
forgive their proper consent and because
the target was a wrong one in the sense
that these kids the father had HIV the
mother didn't but the kids would not
have been born with HIV had this not
happened so he was now I wasn't treating
something that they had he was trying to
give them and enhancement wait how do we
know that they wouldn't have been born
with HIV is that just not how it
transmits in that so we have all kinds
of technologies like washing sperm that
make it so that if you are a man with
HIV in the United States and you want to
have a baby with a woman who doesn't
have HIV it's it there are lots and lots
of ways okay you will get that you you
you will have a baby if you if you get
proper care that doesn't have HIV so
it's not like these kids were going to
have HIV they weren't and so one is
although there's not a clear line
between therapy and enhancement this was
clearly an enhancement and my thought is
we will be enhancing ourselves in the
future and probably in the future we
should be enhancing cuz it's just like
we're a we're buggy we've evolved over
billions of years evolution has made all
kinds of trade-offs and sometimes those
trade-offs are bad for us individually
and so it's terrible when people die
young of terrible genetic diseases it's
terrible when old people get demand
and lose their minds I don't want that
if we can make little tweaks that we've
figured out I'd say like all power to us
like why not that's the history of our
of our species we need to be careful but
for here for the first step on using
this incredibly powerful technology on a
human it would have been more
responsible if we had done it five years
from now in a very responsible very
transparent way addressing a target
where there would have been a kid would
have otherwise been born with a deadly
genetic disease and then we would have
had like here in the beginning you said
let's talk about the good stuff and then
we'll talk about the scary stuff it's
better to start with the good stuff
because people are primed to be
terrified and so I just would have been
so much better had we done it that way
[Music]